Imaginez être un jeune aujourd'hui,
ayant besoin d'un emploi, à la recherche d'un gagne-pain,
prêt à bâtir un avenir
et les opportunités sont difficiles à trouver.
Les jeunes me disent également
qu'ils s'inquiètent de ne pas acquérir les compétences dont ils ont besoin.
A nouveau, ils ont raison.
Nous vivons à une époque
où le monde change si vite en matière d'emploi.
Nous sommes au cœur de la quatrième révolution industrielle.
Les jeunes ne veulent pas être
dans des fermes ni des communautés rurales.
Ils veulent être en ville.
Ils veulent acquérir les compétences utiles pour les emplois du futur.
Ils veulent apprendre les technologies numériques et vertes.
Ils veulent avoir l'opportunité d'apprendre l'agriculture moderne.
Ils veulent apprendre le commerce et l’entrepreneuriat
afin de pouvoir créer leur propre entreprise.
Ils veulent être infirmiers, radiologues, pharmaciens et médecins.
Ils veulent avoir toutes les compétences dont ils auront besoin à l'avenir.
Ils veulent apprendre les métiers, comme la construction et l'électricité.
Ce sont toutes les professions dont un pays a besoin,
ainsi que toutes les professions qui n'ont pas encore été inventées.
Les jeunes me disent également qu'ils s'inquiètent de la violence.
A la maison, en ligne, à l'école, dans leur communauté.
A nouveau, ils ont raison.
Un jeune peut avoir des centaines d'amis sur les réseaux sociaux
mais quand il a besoin de trouver un visage amical,
quelqu'un qui peut être là en tant qu'ami, à qui parler,
il ne trouve personne.
Ils sont confrontés à l'intimidation, au harcèlement et plus encore.
Des centaines de millions d'entre eux sont confrontés à l'exploitation,
à la maltraitance et à la violence.
Toutes les sept minutes, un adolescent ou une adolescente
quelque part dans le monde est tué par un acte de violence.
Les filles me disent
qu'elles sont particulièrement inquiètes au sujet de leur avenir.
Malheureusement, elles ont aussi raison.
Les filles sont confrontées aux préjugés et à la discrimination.
Elles sont confrontées aux mariages précoces
et aux grossesses précoces qui mettent leur vie en danger.
Prenez la population des États-Unis.
Multipliez-la par deux.
C'est le nombre de femmes mariées avant leur 18ème anniversaire.
Six cent cinquante millions.
Nombre d'entre elles sont devenues mères alors qu'elles étaient encore enfants.
Une femme sur trois sera confrontée à de la violence physique
ou à une agression sexuelle durant sa vie.
Il n'est pas étonnant que les filles s'inquiètent de leur avenir.
Ces crises urgentes ne sont peut-être pas une réalité
dans votre vie ou dans votre quartier.
Peut-être avez-vous eu l'opportunité d'avoir une bonne éducation,
des compétences exploitables et d'obtenir un emploi.
Peut-être n'avez-vous jamais été confronté à la violence,
aux préjugés ou à la discrimination.
Mais il y a des dizaines de millions de jeunes qui ne sont pas si chanceux.
Et ils sonnent l'alarme pour leur avenir.
C'est pourquoi l'UNICEF et nos nombreux partenaires publics et privés
lancent une nouvelle initiative mondiale.
Les jeunes lui ont donné son nom.
Elle s'appelle « Generation Unlimited », « Génération sans limite »,
ou « Gen-U » ou « Gen you ».
Ce qu'ils disent c'est : « C'est notre moment, c'est notre tour,
c'est notre avenir. »
Notre objectif est très clair.
Nous voulons tous les jeunes à l'école, en apprentissage, en formation
ou dans un emploi adapté à leur âge d'ici à l'année 2030.
Cet objectif est urgent, il est nécessaire, il est ambitieux.
Mais nous pensons qu'il est aussi atteignable.
Nous faisons appel à des solutions de pointe
et à de nouvelles idées.
Des idées qui donneront aux jeunes une chance pour leur avenir.
Nous n'avons pas toutes les réponses
alors nous faisons appel aux entreprises, aux gouvernements, aux ONG,
au monde universitaire, aux communautés, aux innovateurs pour qu'ils nous aident.
Gen-U sera une plateforme ouverte
où les gens peuvent partager leurs idées et leurs solutions
au sujet de ce qui fonctionne, ce qui ne fonctionne pas
et, surtout, ce qui pourrait fonctionner.
Si nous pouvons ajouter à ces idées un capital d'amorçage,
quelques bons partenaires
et de la bonne volonté politique,
nous pensons pouvoir toucher des milliers et millions de gens
à travers le monde.
Avec ce projet, nous allons également faire quelque chose de nouveau.
Nous allons concevoir et co-créer avec les jeunes.
Avec Gen-U, ils tiendront les rênes,
ils nous guideront sur le chemin.
En Argentine, il y a un programme où nous mettons en relation les élèves
dans des communautés rurales, éloignées, montagneuses et difficiles d'accès
avec une personne qu'ils ont rarement vue :
un professeur de l'enseignement secondaire.
Ces élèves viennent en classe, un professeur du village les y rejoint
et ils sont mis en relation en ligne avec des écoles urbaines.
Le professeur de l'enseignement secondaire
leur enseigne les technologies numériques
et une bonne éducation d'enseignement secondaire
sans qu'ils aient à quitter leur communauté.
En Afrique du Sud, il y a un programme appelé « Techno Girls ».
Ce sont des filles issues de quartier défavorisés
qui étudient dans le domaine des STIM :
science, technologie, ingénierie et maths.
Elles ont la possibilité d'être jumelées avec des travailleurs.
C'est ainsi qu'elles peuvent se voir
dans des emplois en ingénierie,
en science et, peut-être, dans le programme spatial.
Au Bangladesh,
nous avons des partenaires qui forment des dizaines de milliers de jeunes
à des métiers
afin qu'ils deviennent réparateurs de motos
ou agents de service en téléphonie mobile.
Ce sont des opportunités d'avoir leur propre gagne-pain.
Et peut-être même d'avoir leur propre entreprise.
Au Vietnam,
il y a un programme où nous assortissons de jeunes entrepreneurs
avec les besoins dans leurs communautés locales.
Avec ce programme, un groupe s'est réuni
et a décidé de résoudre le problème du transport
des personnes handicapées dans leurs communautés.
Avec un mentor et un capital d'amorçage,
ils ont développé une application pour aider toute la communauté.
J'ai vu comment ces programmes peuvent faire la différence.
Quand j'étais au Liban, j'ai visité un programme appelé « Girls Got IT »,
« Les filles gèrent » ou « Les filles dans la technologie ».
Dans ce programme, les filles qui ont étudié
l'informatique et les STIM
ont l'opportunité de travailler aux côtés de jeunes professionnels
afin d'apprendre directement
ce que c'est d'être une architecte, une conceptrice ou une scientifique.
Quand vous voyez ces filles, un sourire sur le visage,
des éclats dans les yeux,
elles sont si enthousiastes, elles ont de l'espoir pour leur avenir.
Elles veulent changer le monde.
Avec ce programme et ces mentors,
elles peuvent le faire.
Mais ces idées et programmes ne sont qu'un début.
Cela ne touchera qu'une fraction des jeunes que nous devons toucher.
Nous voulons trouver des moyens d'augmenter la portée de ces idées.
De toucher plus de jeunes dans plus de communautés,
dans plus d'endroits dans le monde.
Nous voulons rêver en grand.
Serait-il possible que chaque école, partout dans le monde,
peu importe si elle est éloignée, à la montagne,
voire dans un camp de réfugiés,
serait-il possible qu'elle soit connectée à internet ?
Pourrions-nous avoir une traduction instantanée pour les jeunes
afin qu'ils puissent avoir une bonne éducation
dans leur langue, partout dans le monde ?
Serait-il possible
de mettre en lien l'éducation dans votre école
et les compétences dont vous allez avoir besoin
pour obtenir un emploi dans votre communauté ?
Afin de pouvoir passer de l'école au travail.
Et plus encore.
Pouvons-nous tous aider ?
Dans notre vie quotidienne et sur notre lieu de travail,
pouvons-nous soutenir les jeunes ?
Les jeunes nous demandent des apprentissages,
des jumelages, des stages.
Pourrions-nous faire cela ?
Les jeunes nous demandent également des programmes de travail-étude,
des endroits où ils peuvent apprendre et gagner de l'argent.
Pourrions-nous faire cela
et prendre contact avec une communauté voisine,
qui est moins avantagée, pour l'aider ?
Les jeunes disent également vouloir aider les autres jeunes.
Ils veulent plus d'espace, plus voix au chapitre,
afin de pouvoir se réunir pour s'entraider.
Dans les centres de traitement du VIH, dans les camps de réfugiés,
mais aussi pour mettre un terme au harcèlement en ligne
et aux mariages précoces.
Nous avons besoin d'idées, de petites et de grandes idées,
d'idées qui sont locales et mondiales.
Après tout, cela est de notre responsabilité.
Une énorme génération de jeunes va hériter de notre monde.
Il est de notre devoir de laisser un héritage d'espoir et d'opportunités
pour eux, mais aussi avec eux.
Les jeunes représentent 25% de la population.
Mais ils représentent 100% de notre avenir.
Ils demandent d'avoir une chance
de bâtir un monde meilleur.
Leur demande devrait être notre vocation.
La vocation de notre ère.
Il est temps, le besoin est urgent.
Et 1,8 milliard de jeunes attendent.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)